Yeah. What? What?
Evangelist missionary. Yes.
say uh doctor the brother is a
missionary and he's asking that when
Jesus performed miracle raising uh the
dead to alive and giving uh sight to the
blind Jesus was using whose power his
power or the power of this uh holy
spirit
The brother was asked a very important
question.
>> I know
>> he asked that when Jesus Christ peace be
upon him gave life to the dead whose
power did he use and the reply to this
is given in the Quran.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Imran
chapter number three verse number 39
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him was
sent as a messenger to the one Israel
and he gave life to the dead with the
permission of Allah
all the miracles that are done by all
the prophets not only Jesus whether by
Muhammad peace be upon him by Jesus
peace be upon him by Moses peace be upon
him all the miracles are done by
almighty God So when Jesus gave life to
the dead, the Quran says he said be
nilah wake up in the name of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala. When he healed
those born blind and lepers, he did it
in the name of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. All the messengers even Musa
Alisam when he parted the sea, he did it
with the help of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. So all the messengers whenever
they did any miracles, it was a miracle
done by Allah subhanana wa ta'ala to
prove that these people are messengers
of God. Hope the answer the question.